he did not use geometry okay
so we're working on cool on the scheme
okay it can't be like this no power in
it so the drill he's gonna offer
resistance you can go ahead okay and I
don't want to go up with my foot and
then down you'll you'll feel some
gravitational energy when you come down
but you won't ever get down in when
you're actually trying to apply force so
as I go up and he pushes on my sword
you see I won't reach that top okay so
that's not what we're doing so and it's
not in my arm that's not right my grip
is barely it is barely in I'm gonna drop
my weight so I can engage just like in
the you Miyaichi video and going to
engage the front follow my foot and the
front ball my split the mid foot of both
feet okay so that I can have that kind
of ledge that I'm gonna push on and then
I keep that level I just move my face
forward so I don't want to drop and then
try to do that drop
drop there's really nothing in that has
the flexion of the midsection is the
same as always
so it's percussive it's projecting okay
let's try that two things as you lower
your weight don't pull your center of
gravity forward
don't step push push it in the back
because when you have the when you step
like this right step your center of
gravity right it's getting in between
your feet and you want to push it push
it forward do you see that there's a
moment where nothing's happening
nothing's moving your foot moves now
they're centered right in between and
instead it just goes forward you guys
see that
alright secondly you you have the same
concept that always a psyche is here in
the grip so no I am generating that same
friction by matching the young energy of
the wood and the floor so I just loosely
here pushing my center forward loose
scrips
you see see how loose loose loose so
this is to help he's gonna hold on hold
on to my dad you just watch your face
that you don't get stabbed when you come
back in okay let's try that
so it's gonna be right when we touch ooh
I'm gonna do this and now I'm adding the
continuous violence of action they
really were doing this by initial
acceleration and I'm going to keep going
forward so right when we touch this is
it
all right let's try
so I am NOT going to be committed to say
God and my kid I'm not gonna half-ass
this we want that violence of action
okay I don't want him grabbing my sword
I want him to deal with the onslaught of
my aggressiveness it's kind of like if I
throw if I throw my punch
he might block it but he's got all that
aggressiveness okay
trying to occupy his mind by occupying
his space so this isn't it he'll grab
your sword and beat you with it okay
your your mind is your in and so he's
gonna do it now don't make me just grab
your sword there's little hesitation and
if I do grab it you're just gonna keep
it going
[Music]
check my body out yes got it
okay let's try that can review your your
sword is getting grabbed because you're
just not aggressive on the okay if you
if you come in and you stick that thing
in his face he's gotta choose between
getting out away and being conscious
enough to grab his story
okay so if he does about your sword down
right and just like you saw him - mmm
keep that bonds of action so it is again
right don't go like this reconcile the
angle that he has think you're getting
keep disturbing him right go ahead do it
everything right so see how he's turning
it oh look I come around to say Oh turns
it is another way doesn't matter they're
ready go like that you see boom another
way right same thing oh okay keep that
violence that actually going so that's
his intention on the first drill all of
that's what he's trying to do and I'm
going to neutralize it
[Music]
okay try so and so I'm going to keep
that violence of action going
it's actually my safety if I can
overwhelm her psychologically this is
cutting and we're gonna get there okay
so Michael spirit has to be in into this
so we come in
don't start skiing like this y'all
jacked up from the last rep do the move
you ski in to save your life okay
okay then when I train that way
now you're trading that Budo love you're
gonna have to reconcile all this crap
inside of you
okay and you have to have the perfect my
is representative of the perfect mind
okay